So that's really all I wanted to say about genetic algorithms.
I mean, there's lots of tweaky things that you need to
do to get this to work very effectively. You have some
choice about how to represent the input, and you have some
choice about how you can do your selection, and your fit
to finding your fitness function. But, at a generic level, this
is, this is, it's a, it's a useful thing. Some people
call genetic algorithms the second best solution to any given problem.
>> Hmm.
>> So, it's a good thing to have in your toolbox. But
I think that's, that's really it. That's all I wanted to say about
randomized optimization. So what have we learned?
>> Well, we learned about random optimization period. That that
there is a notion of optimization in the first place.
>> So, we talked about optimization in general
and then we, what was the randomized part?
>> Well, we'd take random steps where we
start off in random places. Or, we'd do random
kind, well actually that's really it. You take
random steps, you start off in random places and
it's a way to overcome when you can't take a natural gradient step.
>> That's right. So did we talk, and we
talked about some particular randomization.
Er, sorry, randomized optimization algorithms.
>> Let's see. There was randomized hill climbing.
>> And we had 2 flavors of that.
>> Right. We did simulated annealing. And, we did genetic algorithms.
>> And don' t forget, that we talked a little bit about how this all connects
back up with learning, because in many
cases, we're searching some parameter space to
find a good classifier, a good regression
function. A later in this particular sub-unit
we're going to be talking about, finding good
clusterings. And so, this notion of finding
something that's good, finding a way to,
to be optimal is pervasive through apache learning.
>> Oh that make sense. Well, there, well, if we're trying to remember all
these other things we learned. We
also learned that AI researchers like analogies.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Both simulating annealing and generic
algorithms are analogies. And they don't
just like analogies, they like taking
analogies and pushing them until they break.
>> Indeed, actually hill climbing [LAUGH] is an analogy too.
>> Yeah, actually, right? Every single thing that we
did is an analogy to something. Okay, that's good. The
other thing that we learned, which I think is
important, is that there's no way to talk about cross,
crossover without getting a bunch of people in the studio to giggle. [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, genetic algorithms make people blush.
>> Okay, that's pretty good, but Michael you
know, I'm, I'm looking at all this and
now that you put all these words together
on one slide, I have 2 observations I want to
make. That that are kind of bothering me. So,
one is, I'm looking at hill climbing that makes
sense, hill climbing restarts makes sense, simulated annealing
makes sense, [INAUDIBLE] but you know what, they don't
really remember a lot. So, what do I mean by that?
So you do all this hill climbing and you go 8
billion steps, and then what happens? You end up with the
point. You do simulated annealing. You do all this fancy stuff
with slowly changing your temperature, and creating swords with black smiths,
and all that other stuff you talked about and in the
end, at every step, the only thing you remember is, where
you are and maybe where you last were. And with genetic algorithms,
it's a little more complicated that because you keep a population,
but really you're just keeping track of where you are, not
where you've been. So in some sense, the only difference between
the 1 millionth iteration, and the 1st iteration is that you might
be at a better point. And it just feels like, if
you're going to go through all this trouble of going through what is
some complicated space that hopefully has some structure, there should be
some way to communicate information about that structure as you go along.
And that just, that sort of bothers. So that's
one thing. The second thing is, what I really
liked about simulating annealing, other than, you know, the
analogy and hearing you talk about strong swords, is that
it came out at the end with a really
nice result, which is this Boltzmann distribution, that there's
some probability distribution that we can understand, that is
actually trying to model. So, here are my questions then.
It's the long way of asking a real
simple question. Is there something out there, something
we can say more about? Not just keeping
track of points, but keeping track of structure
and information. And is there some way that
we can take advantage of the fact that,
all of these things are somehow tracking probability
distributions just by their very nature of being randomized.
>> That's, that's outstanding. Yes, very good, very good question.
It is true that these are all kind of amnesic,
right? They kind of just wander around, and forget
everything about what they learned. They don't really learn about
the optimization space itself. And use that information to be
more effective. There are some other algorithms that these are,
these are kind of the simplest algorithms, but you can re-combine
these ideas you know, sort of cross-over style, to get
other more powerful algorithms. There's one that's called taboo search,
that specifically tries to remember where you've been, and you're
supposed to avoid it. Right, they become taboo regions.
To stay, with the idea that you should stay away
from regions where you've already done a lot of evaluations,
so you cover the space better. And then there's other
methods that are, have been popular for a while
that are gaining in popularity, where they explicitly model the
probability distribution over where good solutions might be. So they
might be worth actually talking a little more about that.
>> Okay, so go ahead. Well, so I kind of added time.
Maybe maybe you could look into this, I can
give you some references and maybe you can report back.
>> Fine.
>> [LAUGH]
You'll learn, you'll learn very well by doing that.
>> Yes sir.
>> [LAUGH] Alright, we'll see you then, then.
>> Okay, I'll see you then, then too. Bye, Michael.
>> Bye Charles.